pourquoi le Maroc refuse-t-il l'aide de
la France de la France aux États-Unis
des pays du monde entier ont proposé
leur aide au Maroc qui a été frappé par
un puissant séisme ce vendredi 8
septembre mais la plupart de ces pays
attendent encore le feu vert de Rabat
pour déployer des secours et si Emmanuel
Macron a rappelé que la France était
prête à venir en aide au Maroc à la
seconde où les autorités marocaines le
jugeront utile plusieurs raisons
expliqueraient le silence marocain tout
commence en juillet 2021 avec l'affaire
Pegasus ce scandale d'écoute
téléphonique aurait permis au régime
marocain d'espionner le téléphone
personnel d'Emmanuel Macron via une
société israélienne depuis la relation
entre les deux pays est très
conflictuelle et puis il y a le
non-respect par les autorités marocaines
des accords de reconduite aux frontières
concernant notamment les étrangers en
situation irrégulière en France enfin et
surtout c'est la question du Sahara
occidental qui envenime la crise cette
région est disputée par le Maroc et les
indépendantistes saharaoui du Front
Polisario soutenu par l'Algérie la
France elle s'en remet aux Nations unies
pour une solution négociée une position
qui ne satisfait pas le Maroc à ce stade
le Maroc n'a accepté l'aide que de
quatre pays l'Espagne la Grande-Bretagne
le Qatar et les Émirats arabes unis à
Paris la ministre des Affaires
étrangères Catherine Colonna a dit
qu'elle ne voulait pas de mauvaise
querelles avec le Maroc selon elle c'est
un pays souverain maître de ses choix
qui a pris la décision de prioriser
l'arrivée d'aide en s'adressant au cas
par cas à certains pays peu avant le
séisme le Roi Mohammed VI s'est
entretenu au téléphone avec Emmanuel
Macron pour la première fois depuis
plusieurs mois
[Musique]